was macht den schon wieder der
praktikant wo ist eigentlich christoph
ohne scherz christoph hat mir gesagt
dass er sich verliebt hat und seine
gedanken gerade ganz woanders stehen und
deshalb hat er mir gesagt ich soll jetzt
die videos machen
er hat mir aber auch versprochen dass er
ab nächste woche wieder das heißt das
nächste dienstags video gibt es dann
wieder von christoph und bis dahin gibt
es die top 5 news jetzt vor mir unter
anderem mit dem thema das ist eine
impfung gegen hiv gibt viel spaß
hiv impfung entwickelt ein komplett
neuer ansatz in der impf technik sollen
nun das impfen gegen hiv ermöglichen
der hi virus ist besonders gefährlich da
sich seine oberflächenstruktur ständig
verändert und unser immunsystem den
erreger deswegen nicht bekämpfen kann
doch ein paar wissenschaftler aus
florida haben nun einen sehr
unkonventionellen und vor allem einen
kreativen weg gefunden um den erreger
unschädlich zu machen und zwar durch ein
bestimmtes protein das protein doch
quasi an die virus zelle an so dass sich
der erreger nicht mehr weiter vermehren
kann
anstatt die zellen zu zerstören wird
also quasi der anschluss einfach nur
verdeckt und zahlreiche hiv-1 varianten
werden dadurch einfach unschädlich
gemacht das protein namens ecd vier lg
wird momentan an affen getestet
diese werden mit dem schutz mehrere
monate lang nicht infiziert obwohl sie
regelmäßig neuen erregern ausgesetzt
werden es gibt allerdings auch kritik
daran hatten die iren gespritzt bekommen
ist noch nicht klar ob die häufigsten
infektionsgebiet die schleimhäute auch
durch das protein geschützt werden
dunkle materie könnte die dinosaurier
getötet haben eine neue studie hält
dunkle materie für den auslöser des
massensterbens vor 66 millionen jahren
bei dem über 90 der lebensformen damals
ausgestorben sind unter anderem ja auch
die dinosaurier und noch viel
erschreckender das ganze soll wieder
passieren denn unser sonnensystem
durchquert alle 26 bis 30 millionen
jahre eine art galaktischen scheibe
das ist eine region in unserer galaxie
in der besonders viele sternenhaufen
angesiedelt sind und man vermutet dort
auch eine menge dunkler materie die
existenz von dunkler materie konnte bis
jetzt noch nicht experimentell bewiesen
werden
trotzdem gehen viele wissenschaftler
davon aus dass dunkle materie bis zu 26
prozent der masse unseres universums
ausmacht und vor allem in form von
gravitation mit atomarer masse
interagiert die studie geht jetzt davon
aus dass sich der erdkern stark erhitzt
wenn wir quasi durch diese galaktischen
scheibe hindurch fliegen
dadurch wäre eine erhöhte
vulkanaktivität zum beispiel durchaus
denkbar
außerdem vermutet man dass in dieser
region vermehrt kometen anzutreffen sind
die wahrscheinlichkeit dass einer dieser
kometen mit der erde kollidiert und
durch den aufprall das klima verändert
wird wäre dort wesentlich größer
neuartiges objektiv erfunden
ein forscherteam aus harvard hat eine
neue art von objektiv hergestellt dass
die welt der fotografie revolutionieren
könnte im gegensatz zu herkömmlichen
objektiven die von 3 cm länge bis zu
gigantischen metern groß werden können
ist dieses neue objektiv beinahe
zweidimensional
denn es ist nur 60 nanometer dick dieses
neue objektiv besteht aus einem die
elektrischen material und benutzten
nanoantennen um ein breites spektrum an
lichtwellen brechen zu können
das licht von normalen objektiven wird
in mehreren glaslinsen gebrochen
dabei treffen verschiedene wellenlängen
also auch verschiedene farben die man
hier sehen kann auch auf verschiedene
punkte auf dem sensor und das führt
allgemein zu einer bild unschärfe die
neue technik soll dieses problem umgehen
und alle wellenlängen exakt auf einen
punkt bündeln können die patentierte
erfindung soll so schnell wie möglich
auf den markt kommen wo sie dann
womöglich alle arten von kameras und
objektiven komplett umgestaltet die
möglichkeiten sind beinahe endlos
fingerlänge deutet auf untreue hin
eine studie hat die verbindung zwischen
den fingern eines mannes und seinem
verhalten in der gegenwart von frauen
festgestellt
je mehr testosteron der mann im bauch
seiner mutter erhalten hat desto größer
ist der ringfinger im vergleich zum
zeigefinger und desto größer ist auch
die wahrscheinlichkeit dass der mann
untreu ist denn männer die mehr
testosteron ausgesetzt werden neigen
dazu mit möglichst vielen frauen
schlafen zu wollen
umgekehrt sind männer deren ring und
zeigefinger er gleich lang sind sowie
beim ihr treuer und aufmerksamer
gegenüber ihren partnern und auch
gegenüber anderen frauen sollen diese
männer im schnitt besser und netter sein
bei frauen kann er schluss über die
finger allerdings nicht gezogen werden
so die studie
malaria krankheit entwickelt sich weiter
in den letzten 15 jahren konnte die
anzahl der todesopfer durch malaria
beinahe halbiert werden
demmin isin ist ein pflanzlicher
wirkstoff der eine entscheidende rolle
bei der bekämpfung gegen die
tropenkrankheit spielt doch anscheinend
hat sich der erreger weiter entwickelt
eine abstimmung der malaria krankheit
ist immun gegen genau dieses mini sie
und breitet sich momentan über
kambodscha vietnam und thailand in
richtung indien aus experten halten dies
für eine klare bedrohung und
unterstreichen den ernst der lage
denn wenn die krankheit indien erreicht
hat dann wird sich wahrscheinlich rasend
schnell ausbreiten
zusätzlich dazu ist über diese neuartige
abstammung kaum etwas bekannt da sie
erst seit kurzem aufgetreten ist
es gibt nur sehr wenige alternativen zum
pflanzenstoff at me ziehen so der
experte dr mudrow außerdem kämpfen wir
im moment nicht nur gegen malaria
sondern auch gegen ebola von dieser
krankheit haben in den letzten wochen
viel weniger gehört als zum beispiel
noch letztes jahr wie sowie diese
epidemie trotzdem nicht vergessen dürfen
erfahren in diesem video alle links zu
den angesprochenen themen geht's wie
immer unten in der video beschreibung zu
rap und zum blog geht's wie immer hier
und was meint ihr wie entwickeln sich
ebola malaria und hiv weiter kann die
menschheit überleben oder werden sich
die viren immer weiterentwickeln bis sie
schließlich gegen alle impfstoffe immun
sind sehr spannendes thema diskutiert es
wie immer mit uns unten in den
kommentaren und ansonsten sage ich
vielen dank fürs zuschauen bis zum
nächsten mal
patrick